[Musik]
traditionell zum nationalfeiertag
präsentiert sich das österreichische
bundesheer mit einer informations und
leistungsschau vor beeindruckender
kulisse in wien
nach den wiener donauinselfest übrigens
die zweitgrößte veranstaltung in
österreich
wie jedes jahr findet zum gedenken an
die toten soldaten und opfer des
widerstands eine kranzniederlegung durch
den bundespräsidenten und die
bundesregierung statt
[Musik]
zu den hauptwerken ist nationalfeiertag
zählt wie immer angelogen
[Musik]
über 1000 rekruten sind es heuer die ihr
treu gelöbnis ablegen
anschluss können sich die besucher ein
bild von der ausstattung und den
fähigkeiten des bundesheeres machen
[Musik]
auf 7 standort der ist informations und
leistungsschau in der wiener innenstadt
aufgeteilt
[Musik]
von panzern über hubschrauber und sogar
einem flugsimulator
die leistungsschau bietet für jeden
besucher bass
[Musik]